[Music]
well thank you for being here today
congratulations on your epic bike ride
across America think I need to hear a
little bit more about it and explore the
connection between fitness and adventure
and mental well-being which i think is
super important you finish the ride in
July right I finished in September
Oh in September oh it's memories in
there I thought wow Labor Day
that's right oh you start you started
again resume resume didn't yeah yeah yes
I had to start again June 2nd right oh
yeah ok all right yeah well they're here
we're gonna talk about all this kind of
stuff your story's super inspiring what
you've overcome and what you decide to
tackle and and and kind of what I think
you know is most important is what it
means for the rest of us so to set the
stage to provide a little context why
don't we go all the way back to the
beginning right so you end up enlisting
right out like pretty young age yes I
joined the Army National Guard at age 17
haha parents had to co-sign what was
that what was the motivation like where
it was that something you always wanted
to do I always want to do something like
that
it was between the military or possibly
the FBI I looked into bone and I just
felt a little more of a calling toward
the military I always wanted to be part
of something bigger than myself I craved
a challenge constantly I played sports
and everything and I really enjoy that
the physical challenge the mental
challenge you know to see how far I can
push myself and and push others - did
you grow up in a military family you
have brothers and sisters
I have one sister no teens your question
no I I have two great uncles that served
one was a full-bird colonel in the Army
he's an intelligence officer
communications officer he actually
participated he had a hand in the moon
landing he had a signed thing from NASA
and all these things and it it was
amazing he didn't touch he was very
soft-spoken and didn't talk very much
about it so I
no a lot of the the details who probably
could it but aside from that I I don't
know of of any other yeah everything but
it wasn't a shock I don't think because
I was always very outdoorsy and I liked
roughing and I liked camping and being
in nature playing with every animal I
could find and it just I was always
fascinated by the outdoors and I'm
pushing myself in different ways so it
just fit if it really well and your
parents were cool hood and everything
yes yes and know what my mom couldn't
sign it she had my dad do it she's like
I couldn't do I couldn't possibly do but
they were extremely supportive and very
proud like that's my ultimate goal I
always to make my parents proud you know
they always been supportive of my dreams
and everything like that you grew up in
Ohio right yes yeah North Central Ohio
so once you sign on the dotted line like
what happens how does it work well I was
still in high school I had to wait to
graduate to go to basic training and so
you go off to basic training and I
where'd you do that it was Fort Jackson
South Carolina when they kind of just
break you down and build you back up
uh-huh
which is a wonderful experience I almost
feel like you get a huge you get to
start life steps further just based on
knowing your personal limitations or or
not knowing them or wondering if you
even have them and at the end of it
you're like is there nothing I can't
push myself to do or so I don't know it
equips you with all these skill sets
right out of the gate you have to learn
things very quickly and the leadership
aspect stepping up and then the bonds
you form and they're being kind of a
team you don't really recognize color in
a way except for you wear green and you
bleed red and those are the only two
colors that should matter yeah and we're
a unit and you you know jump in front of
a bullet for one another it's this
really cool bond foundation and
camaraderie that you gain right right
off the bat you're introduced to all
these things so I really I think it's
something that we don't really have in
our culture with the exception of
playing sports which is you know a
facsimile of that but a situation in
which the stakes are
you know not nearly as high of course no
it gets intense with sport it's a lot
like sports it's also a lot like I think
the medical field a pair especially
paramedics nurses doctor that the
medical field fireman a fireman police
there's a lot of similarities between
those careers too and you really bond
quickly over intense situations I think
that's what makes that bond so solid and
so profound is the intensity of the
situations that you're in and what is
the bootcamp experience like in you know
my only point of reference is what I see
in movies and TV right is it like that
is it you know honestly yeah watch it it
really is there at least when I was in
it may have changed I went to boot camp
2001 and they get right in your face and
scream and uh now they can't you know
maybe throw you to the ground and things
like that
or throw things at you but uh they can
sling some pretty harsh you know strings
around
what uh what month I mean was it before
or after September 11th
oh I joined I joined prior to September
11th really before so I'd completed
basic and everything I was actually
attending college when September 11th
happened and then I they did the
original the initial infiltration the
next year 2003 2000 2003 I received a
call to that my unit was going to be
activated right so you're deployed to
Iraq yes for Operation Iraqi Freedom
yes 2004 uh-huh for 12 months so explain
to me that experience
well you grow up very quickly
I thought basic training shot me ahead
but I turned 21 over there so you just
have to you have to figure things out
really quickly and it's it's actually
amazing how fast you adjust to it and
and how quickly the environment and the
sounds and the smells all become kind of
normal and it was an intense year it
definitely was
and what was a day-in-the-life like when
you were when you were deployed it
varied it did vary drastically I would
say on average let's say when I maybe
did guard duty and the perimeter or
something like that it was 12 hours
shifts I did the night shift and what's
a shift like what are you doing on a
shift you basically well it's like a
statics it was like static security we'd
sit with the m249 the squad automatic
weapon and there was different sites you
would use for the thermal things like
that cos night you would just you know
make sure everything is safe no one's
coming in and things like that and uh
every day every day was different but
the same but there was always like the
the worry that either you would be
killed or your friends would be so it
was it was very high intensity mm-hmm I
think that's a lot of why we remember
every second of it I think when your
sentence senses are all heightened you
absorb things differently it's so
permanent like I can't remember what I
maybe did a week ago but I remember
right you know like every cemented in
your head detail oh right right
so on yeah it was it was a very the year
went by quickly you know and we spent so
long downplaying it that I guess we just
kind of make light of the deployment
sometimes when we get back cuz we don't
really want to paint the picture for
right sometimes but as almost a survival
mechanism for yourself right so if you
downplay it then perhaps the toll it's
taking on you isn't real or isn't as
intense as what is actually happening
it's like when you don't feel well but
you don't say anything and you can kind
of control it or you know it doesn't
become real then when you say something
it's like okay now I really don't feel
like a physically you know and maybe
that's maybe that's part of the fear of
talking about some of the things is we
don't want some of the maybe the things
we're dealing with to be real or yeah
that's a really great way to look at it
that's very
true and when you're there I would
imagine that you lost some colleagues
yes that was probably the probably the
biggest factor for some of my issues is
is the fact that we had to come home
without everybody I was particularly
close to one of the soldiers that was
killed over there and so there's
definitely a an aspect of guilt that you
carry and in some days are probably
heavier than others I would say and
sometimes you don't think about it for a
while and then you'll see something and
you kind of it really does I think build
over time which is a lot of a big part
of what led me to ultimately doing this
cycling trip I just it was a combination
of do I deserve to be here or deserve
good things mixed with feeling guilty
about that because I'm not living and
honoring my friends sacrifice by
isolating you know I'd begin isolating
quite a bit over the last decade I would
say yeah and I want to really tighten I
want to really understand PTSD and how
it impacted you and what it's all about
but I think it would be I'm still trying
to understand what you had what you
endured while you were overseas to help
me kind of wrap my head around what it
would be like to come home and live with
that like were you on patrols were you
like on the front like was there just
constant bond like what it you know
paint me the picture of like the
experience of being in Iraq at that
moment yes it varies person to person my
I think my biggest things are low loud
booms I would say because we would have
you know mortars and artillery and stuff
come in almost daily close enough to
where I would you know shake the
buildings and things like that on the
base yes yeah I was at Camp Spiker near
Tikrit Iraq
so I anything that's kind of like a low
boom I just kind of pause because
usually it would be it wouldn't just be
one and you just kind of pause and
listen and wait and stuff and then you
get mad at yourself
your home and it's not it's not a mortar
ser you know like chill out you know and
on other things like in particular my
rotation it was one of the first
rotations with women and there was a
million dollar bond on the head of any
female soldier captured and I that we
were kind of briefed on this you know
when we got there and so there's like an
element of paranoia and uh and and in
the back of my mind I think in the very
back cuz I I loved everyone I served I
trusted them with my life in the very
back your mind it's like a million
dollars is a lot of money to you so
every time you leave the base on patrol
or whatever your the judgment on the
base because I mean we would have Iraqis
come in and do certain tasks on their
right base and everything so is that was
that part of trying to train the Iraqi
army so they could be self-sufficient or
not when I was there not where I was it
was more kind of like different jobs
around the base that they would do so
they they were definitely intermixed
with us here I'm there and I and you're
not you don't I mean conceivably they're
they're cleared somehow to come on the
base but you're always questioning you
know dual motives or whatnot
yeah it's very much so certain I think
the hyper-vigilance and the that kind of
level of paranoia I would say it well
it's it's kind of a char I watch it kind
of watch everything you know consumer
aware of everything all the time which
has to be you know start staying at home
a lot too I just I was getting fatigued
from from all of it and I also was there
ever a moment where you know you were
super in harm's way
yes there was one I rocket like a full
rocket came into the camp and landed in
the front yard of the building that was
typically and I was a street back at the
time and it was it's like the loudest
thing that I could but I've ever heard I
mean everyone people have taken roadside
bumps right right next to them you know
so that's that's different but that
rocket coming in it didn't
kill anybody miraculously it didn't
fully detonate so they had you know the
the guys come in and disarm it and take
it away and everything but it came right
in there was a crater I took a photo and
video of it and everything and it's like
this is the building a horror years
here's where I came in deploy right so
what what would I have even had it bad I
think the kill radius on it it would
have killed a lot I think a lot of
people had it fully detonated it but the
crater itself was huge it was a little
the loudest thing ever
right so I think that's where they like
the low loud booms kind of bothered on
itself like does that still happened
like if you pull up to a car that's
playing a lot of bass know what it is
it's fine I think it's just like unpause
it as fast as possible figure out what
the sound is and what it means and
things like that if you can make sense
of what it is it's like okay fine and
usually you can do that pretty quickly
oh no just things like that but yeah I
just I guess it's it's really a
combination of these types of things and
then kind of missing it all so intensity
the bond over there that you form and
you you hold with these people and then
you come home and I deployed with the
National Guard unit the combat engineers
and so when we got back we kind of went
to our respective units I got pulled
from my current unit to go with this
other units I didn't know them but I got
to know quickly and they were awesome it
was a really well put together unit and
um so we got home and then went our
separate ways and so you kind of lose
touch a little bit too and so I moved
down to Nashville eight years ago and
then I didn't see anybody I served with
anymore and so I also made the mistake
of not becoming involved with
organizations that were in place like
the VFW American Legion and vets those
sorts of things I just didn't I didn't
do it and I think a lot of us maybe make
similar mistakes just not right
continuing to botch right - did you have
a sense that you were suffering from
PTSD or were you trying to pretend that
you weren't
or did you think you were fine like when
you first got back what was that you
know emotionally what did that feel like
what did you feel like you were in
trouble and this needed to be dealt with
or were you just trying to you know pull
yourself up by the bootstraps and move
on with your life I think I think it was
both
but we didn't it was a very quick
out-processing like um they're like you
are you good all right cool are you good
I mean cool so and then we go home I
think I I I would like to believe I was
fine and everything I know I felt like
maybe I didn't relate with with people
so much and I also you know avoided
questions not because they were maybe
too painful to answer or something like
something like that but it takes so much
to even paint the picture and then then
go into the story or going to the
experience and good or bad really and
then you kind of only share some of
those connections with the people that
you were physically there with so if you
don't see them all the time anymore you
start to feel kind of alienated and then
you start you know I mean leading a big
part of that is a normal reaction right
like if you're in a super intense
situation and that then that it ends
there's gonna be you know an acclamation
period to that so the issue then becomes
when does it tip over into a persistent
trauma that is festering beneath the
surface you know when you explain that
I keep thinking about that scene in The
Hurt Locker where Jeremy Renner's like
at the grocery store when he gets back
and it's it's it's very simple in its
aesthetic but it's so powerful because
you realize like he like he's looking at
products on the shelf and he just can't
relate to anything because you know he's
used to a completely different way of
living his life and now suddenly like
overnight that's all changed and he's
supposed to just acclimate to normal
civilian existence and of course that's
you know close to impossible for a lot
of people I would imagine for anybody
really that aspect was very actually
coming back and waiting in line at a
grocery store and people complaining
about standing waiting in line or or
like you said those kinds of little
things it's like do you know how bad it
could actually
like the video yeah good you have it
like those kinds of thoughts come in
I think shortly after you get home or
right away I think that kind of fate is
you get more used to those comforts
again but you kind of crap and
eventually you almost kind of crave
having nothing again that that's another
reason why this bike trip was so amazing
too was the simplicity the lack of
things making something out of nothing
having that challenge and you know I
think that comfort and convenience leave
very little room for appreciation and
you really realize what you do have
though I think the less you have the the
more you feel you have are the more
likely to give or something like that
there's something to that well it's just
weird confusing soup like I imagine
because on the one hand you have this
sense of gratitude for how good we have
it after having an experience like that
and then at the same time to be
suffering I would imagine kind of
enhances the feelings of confusion and
guilt right cuz you're like it's so good
and I'm back here and I'm safe and
everything's fine so why do I feel
terrible writer I think one of my
biggest problems that I was facing
regularly was why am I here and my
friends aren't that kind of thing or it
should have been me that sort of thing
and you don't have to have been deployed
to combat or even be a military veteran
to understand that that happens you know
the Cap'n to anyone anytime losing
someone that survivor's guilt they call
it but that was a huge factor for me was
there was the guilt of coming home
without that we lost three so yeah so
when you come back is there a process by
which you are funneled through like the
Veterans Administration to have you
checked out to make sure that you're
mentally sound like how does all of that
work and how do so many people fall
through fall through the cracks like
what is not working what's broken and
you know what what would you fix if you
could well I think ultimately I think it
comes down to the person being
forthcoming with some of the problems
but we don't tend to do that yeah I know
I'm trying to turn an alarm plane you
know yes yeah definitely and so I think
that they have a system in place but
maybe it's not as persistent you know it
if you have a conversation with a
veteran it's sometimes it takes a
several of those interactions to even
scratch the surface of maybe what
they're thinking or feeling especially
if maybe they they feel like they could
have done more or should have done more
that's the last thing they want people
to know about is they don't want to be
judged for not having done more severe
things a lot alone have someone know
that they that they feel these that they
have these issues based on having not
done as much as they feel they should or
could have which is almost never the
case they we all do everything we can we
follow orders we you know to the best of
our ability we would never want to come
home without anybody and but yeah that
the guilt aspect I think exists in in
every combat vet that has been deployed
with the unit that comes home without
somebody from every war you know that's
across the board an issue yeah well the
statistics are pretty shocking every day
22 vets take their lives
I mean it's so incredibly disheartening
to hear that and as somebody who has no
military experience my only basis of
understanding is what I read in the news
or what I kind of you know come across
here and there and my sense and please
correct me if I'm wrong is that the
Veterans Administration is overwhelmed
there's too many people it's not
adequately staffed and soldiers either
don't avail themselves of those services
or those services become they're
unavailable or they have to wait forever
to get an appointment and because
they're overwhelmed it's very much a you
know a way of just getting prescribed
medication so you have all of these
veterans who are over medic
walking around that then contributes to
this opioid crisis that we're
experiencing right now without really
getting to the root cause or a healthy
protocol for crawling out of this hole
that so many people are you know
experiencing yes it it is uh I mean it's
it comes down to either/or it's mainly
two things it's an individual
responsibility to seek the help and then
I'm having everything in place just so
to facilitate the help needed so I mean
do they have therapists and things like
that yes yes they do then how many
people actually take advantage of that
now I'm not sure about that I know that
I personally went the VA has I mean they
have psychologists psychiatrists I I was
never really into the the one-on-one
kind of counseling it's sometimes it's
difficult for me to funnel my thoughts
into words and everything and like paint
that picture like I mentioned and so I I
rather kind of hang I think it's the
most helpful things to be around other
veterans and socialize with other
veterans but that if you're isolating
that's not possible but back to the VA
they do have that in place they have
counselors and a whole network of of
help before that so it while they do
prescribe they are there
I think quick to prescribe you know the
maybe pain medication or like the mood
Lightner type of medications and or
anything like that they also have all
the other options in place too they even
have activities you can do but yet
that's there I think it it's really for
me it was good going actually going
there and admitting or that I'm doing
these things feeling all all these
things and all that I didn't want to
because it becomes real like you said
earlier yeah you know you admit it then
you actually have to confront it right
and then there's labels and stuff and
there's categories I didn't want to be
lumped into something it's like no I got
this you know I totally I'm totally in
control and
that's that control just sometimes it
just sneaks that sneaks away from you
and then you know kind of a darkness
kind of swoops in here and there and
yeah that's kind of what was happening
to me and what did happen which is
another big reason I I kind of left on
my right knee right yeah I mean my sense
is that there are a lot of veterans who
because they're trained to
compartmentalize and and sort of you
know just take care of business
it makes it less likely that they're
gonna seek that help and you know as you
know the longer you try to repress that
kind of trauma it's going to come out
sideways one way or the other it's
either gonna come in the form of
depression or suicidal ideation or
domestic violence or drug addiction or
alcoholism like it it will manifest at
some point and in your case I mean the
gestation period was quite a long period
of time it's not like you you know
wrestled with this right away I mean you
just did your bike trip you were
deployed in 2003 I mean it's been you
know quite a journey for you to come get
to this place I didn't really actually I
didn't think I was wrestling with it
like you said the I called my journey a
vicious cycle because obviously it's a
bicycle but right there's been some
great by the way oh thank you well it's
like there you know there's all these
other meanings that I've been through
some vicious cycles and it was a mixture
of maybe you know bad decisions and
really good decisions that didn't feel
like fulfilling enough or feel like
enough and I mean by that now the when I
when I first got back basically I began
eating emotionally eating I would say
and I totally abuse food I really did
when I when I got out of the service in
2009 I just it became kind of an answer
to everything you know it wasn't it
wasn't drugs I drank a bit but it was
that the food I mean I equated it with
every emotion and it was my punishment
my reward is everything and I I gained a
hundred pounds after I got out of that
that's crazy
and yeah I was I was that was definitely
part of it is I was this
strong capable machine of a person how
and how could I let this happen and it
just spiraled down so fast
now that I I got a grip on I met another
combat veteran she owned a gym and she
helped me lose you know her workouts
were basically boot can't they were
boots right and I lost that 100 pounds
in a year in 2012 by working out and
just eating right and correct yourself
so you had you know enough sense about
you to address that situation what was
going on inside like emotionally when I
when I became heavier took control of it
or just both I guess I didn't part of it
was I didn't have to I had the
accountability wasn't in place anymore
I had my neck started hurting about
halfway through my deployment I started
getting these kind of shooting pains up
the back of my head and so it worsened
more and more my knees were pretty
banged up from wear and tear and those
were worsening to what caused the neck
pain it wasn't a nice like an isolated
incident it was just I don't know if it
was like the Kevlar the bouncing it just
became really painful like halfway
through and then I didn't I got some
some help I was over there but really I
didn't complain too much about it and
eventually it had become worse I was
encouraged to talk about it with my
leadership and everything and so they
did an eval and ended up marking me
non-deployable
so I wasn't even able to deploy with my
unit again that's why you never you
didn't go back for a second tour right
right I ended up getting I would have
been a lifer I loved the military
yeah it's i-i've said before it's it's
the one thing that's ever made complete
sense in my life and it's been very
difficult to try to fill that gap since
getting out cuz I really did love it it
was definitely my calling yeah and your
life's very regimented they tell you
where to go and everything is very
structured for you you don't have to
really do so much they Tony curse a lot
about do they know ya know and so it's
highly to secure
yeah but now but I I got out I didn't
have the accountability in place and it
was it's such a normal social thing to
do is eat you know but you can't hide it
forever like some other things that you
know you can visually show someone's got
some problem and the weird thing is that
you're somebody who was trained to be
super disciplined right and you're all
about that and capable living in a very
regimented way and then that just falls
apart mm-hmm I was I was supposed to be
very capable and strong you know it was
never about being some it wasn't ever a
superficial or reason for being in shape
it was like you're supposed to be able
to do these things and do these things
when needed and help others and keep
others safe and so I let that go and I
just got really down on myself obviously
and then it was I kept it you know in as
a reaction to being down it was food
food so right but on yeah like you said
I just I did those like a high-intensity
full-body workout 5 days a week and just
ate really clean you know no sugar lower
carb thing like that it was varies the
hundred pounds it takes like a year so
you did it right you've kept it off the
most further my great the but the
interesting thing is that that didn't
that didn't necessarily solve your
problem I'll function right addressing
the underlying trauma yeah right yes I
mean I'm sure it elevated your mood and
helped you in many different ways but it
wasn't necessarily a cure to the main
thing that you were contending with that
was driving the emotional eating to
begin with mm-hmm yes I just it was that
lack of fulfillment I think that sense
of purpose that I gained from serving
just it I couldn't achieve it anymore
and I started a photography business in
2005 when I was still in Ohio and I
continued it to Nashville and I had that
and it was it's going fine too I still
do it I love it you know and I like
bringing that joy to people you know
capturing their moments and everything
and part of me is like you never know
when you're gonna lose someone it's
really important to get these photos
these
people so that makes me do better at my
job also it's kind of a more of an angle
because you never know when you lose
someone but the photography became very
important I mean it was a great outlet a
healthy outlook just like working out
and I just after a while it just my
passion was doing nothing from these
things working out became a passion and
I actually the reason I had to kind of
stop working out is I had I had to have
a major surgery in 2016 and so right
this is like a big deal that explain to
company tell explain the yeah I know
come on we got time here I want to hear
the details we kind of gloss over your
deployment to like no tell us what it
was really like like I know you get you
were you're diagnosed with a
grapefruit-sized cyst in your ovaries
right yeah that's no small thing it was
yeah it was a it was huge so but it was
attached to one of my ovaries and they
there was also a cancer scare involved
and so they said the best case scenario
the best case scenario I would lose an
ovary the worst cases I do have cancer
that I have to do a full hysterectomy
and then remove part of the lining of
like my heart and lung or something like
that it it was really pissed I was like
so drastic I had to sign off on all
these different scenarios but um this
was Thanksgiving in 2016 and so I wasn't
it was a really great shape then and I
was helping other people lose weight I
then my accountability was being there
for others than helping them mm-hmm
which was really important to me I was
helping others again and so I had this
surgery I had do as soon as they found
it I had to stop working out right away
if it had ruptured it could have been
life-threatening sorry I had this major
surgery and the recovery I'm like a huge
scar I mean the recovery was is I think
when everything kind of came to a head
because I I'd lost all that weight I
felt like I was in a pretty good place
I was helping other people break out of
their own prison you know because being
heavy is a physical and mental prison it
really is you're just trapped in your
own body and it was
really nice to play a part in helping
others with that so I felt like I was
giving back in helping in that way and
then I couldn't do that and then the
recovery was very long I couldn't set up
a bed by myself for awhile I mean it was
just I just felt completely defeated
like why am I even try us like am I
gonna start at square one again you know
do I really want to you know you just
kind of talk yourself out of life I
guess what is that connection between
PTSD and hopelessness I think just that
kind of a has-been mentality in a way
where you were this you almost felt like
a god or something like you could do
anything like nothing could stop you and
you felt like you were really doing
something important you were making a
real difference and then once you don't
have that it takes so much to it achieve
those things in your head and once you
don't really have that anymore
you it happens kind of quickly where you
just oh I can't do this
No and so I'll become less active and
then all my body hurts more because I
don't have my muscle base and then I'm
depressed because I'm in pain and then I
you just go down to a vicious cycle
right yeah yeah really
it really is so you happen it's this
downward spiral happens very quickly
right before you know it you're talking
yourself out of having even people that
are you don't want to also you don't
really want to bother anybody with any
of this stuff because you do think you
can handle it yourself at first and then
when you think there's a problem it's
like no I'm supposed to be strong for
others I'm supposed to be the rock and
pull others over their walls and I'm
good at it you know like we're good at
being strong for other people and so
when it comes down to helping ourselves
or spending the time on ourselves I
think it gets trickier there yeah we're
not as good at that I think at least I
wasn't and did not have that that bond
that connection camaraderie when you
return I mean there's nothing you know
you can go to the gym and help other
people lose weight but it's still it's
not the same and then you pick a career
that essentially has you kind of doing
your own thing by yourself right like
you go and you shoot up pictures of
other people but ultimately you're it's
like a solo businessperson situation so
you're not in a member of a team you're
not you know it's almost like and and
and the sense I have is that you're
lacking that connection but rather than
seeking it out in a healthy way you're
doing the opposite like you're isolating
further and further and further which is
only exacerbating the condition yes and
then instead of helping or making a
difference anymore you're letting people
down by coming up with reasons to not
get together with them or not answering
really the messages is often things like
that so then there's guilt compiles I
think that was the biggest factor for me
was is this underlying guilt and then
this building AHA guilt we're the people
were there people in your life who were
saying hey Sarah you know I think
there's something going on here that you
need to deal with no one was like no
thought you were fine mm-hmm yeah I had
that online when you even when you
gained 100 pounds now that I well I
dressed really well to hide it but I
thought I was just this master of
disguise and a few people said something
but it was usually things that would
make me just go eat more like or they've
asked you know have you gained weight
I'm like you already know the answer to
that question you know so I'm gonna go
get Taco Belen but your parents weren't
worried about you or I think maybe it
just people don't wanna hurt my feelings
or something too but they may have made
a comment or two and I of course talked
my way out of anything being wrong or I
just didn't want him to worry and but it
was was there a conscious awareness that
you were trying to mask something or did
you really believe that you were fine no
no I I actually was maybe in the back of
my mind I thought to myself if I eat
enough then I maybe it'll it'll kill me
or something
maybe uh and it almost did item my
cholesterol was in the high to 80s or
something like that it got pretty out of
control with my health and and you're in
like your 20s right mm-hmm
27 28 29 and that's pretty young so but
I don't I'm really glad that I caught it
I think it's it came down to meeting the
right people too if I hadn't met my
friend slash trainer I don't know I
don't know if I'd be here you know I
might have had a stroke or heart attack
like they projected within five years
that your doctor was telling you to get
it under control
well I wasn't going to a doctor oh you
are I hadn't been to a doctor and
probably seven or eight years so what
was the impulse to seek out the trainer
like how did that begin how did you go
from we met on a whim in a parking lot
and someone had been bothering her and I
was staying with her while she waited
for the police to come and that's how we
met and somebody got to talk and she
said she was a combat vet and I was like
no way me too and and I was like oh she
said she owned a gym she knew that I was
not happy as a veteran who was that
sighs and she reached out she's like I
have a gym here and I help people all
the time I used to be it in the 300s
myself which was huge because she
understood the that prison I pension and
so and she was a veteran and that's I
just came out it came down to meeting
the right person and letting them help
letting them help me save myself which
is also a big factor in the bicycle trip
too is the letting people encourage you
and support you right yeah like the
first like being willing to raise your
hand and say I need help not just asking
for help but also being willing to
receive it when it's being offered right
yes very difficult yes usually it's
dismissive kind of a downplay I got it
I'm I'm fine how are you like how can I
help you
achtung yes very much so which that that
is all I really want to do is is better
other people like that's when I feel the
best is when I'm
bettering others yeah I would say which
that was a huge thing that was missing
in my in my life I think mm-hmm making
huge differences for people do you think
that had you not been diagnosed with the
cyst and you would just continue to
train and help people in the gym that
that you would have been okay or do you
think that you were still not really
getting at the core issue like it would
have manifested one way or the other but
the cysts kind of that situation and
being where you were really compelled
forced to stop and be with yourself and
be unable to distract yourself with
external things like going to the gym
really forced you to confront it in a
way that maybe would have taken a lot
longer I thought that not occurred I
think so it was a blessing and a curse
it's kind of like almost like a gift
right in a lot of ways yeah if it well
sitting here now and looking back yeah
it definitely was I think I was
confusing HAP maybe happinesses with
distractions you know I would go to the
gym and forget everything and it was
wonderful and then I wouldn't sleep at
night or something like that
so I think this kind of forced me to
want to try to live again because I did
have you know the cancer scare and all
the such a scary word anyway there
wasn't any present by the way I forgot
to mention those a huge relief yeah your
surgery went fine yes yes mmm it was
better than the best-case scenario they
didn't have to remove anything but the
cyst so I guess things got kind of bad
when I realized that I might not have
the option of having kids I've always
been on the fence anyway but it's nice
to have the option and um I don't know
that all just came together and I guess
this kind of having the surgery and
going through that took me to a bit of a
breaking point there cuz it got kind of
dark right right up until the surgery so
what what was the lowest moment the
darkest day I think I think it was
probably
it was probably it was the day right
before I bought my bicycle right before
I bought the bicycle and I just I knew
after the surgery I'd be limited my my
neck had gotten bad my knees I felt like
I'd have to start all over I'd know
muscle base anymore for because that's
when I'm not really in pain is when I
have the muscle in place and I guess I
just the photography was great but I
just didn't think I'd ever achieve that
sense of fulfillment again and now I
can't even go to the gym and have that
outlet anymore
I just felt like I just didn't even I'm
just not capable of of anything anymore
yeah
was it depression was there suicidal
ideation was there you know what was the
mindset there yes I I definitely was I
guess I I can say that I was fantasizing
about it and that evening was probably
the closest I'd ever come in my head to
to an attempt I had an attempted suicide
prior and I just decided that that I
can't do that to my I've lucked out with
very loving family and I couldn't do it
to my parents so but even in that moment
you didn't have friends or family around
that had a sense that you were going
sideways no no one really knew I was
going through any of this until I I made
a Facebook post about it and just was a
little more vocal about some of the
stuff I was gonna did you say in that
here put this alone so it's a little bit
more in front of you oh I'm sorry yeah
cool
basically I said a lot of the things
that I've said here I expressed and
explained that since getting out of the
military
it feels like I've kind of lived a whole
lifetime and there's really nothing left
to do that's kind of where I derived in
my mind I said that I've had these
nagging gnawing thoughts that I'm really
only living life
to fulfill some sort of obligation to
the people that love me and nothing more
and I felt so guilty about saying that
because everybody that cares for me is
pile like you know I thought she has a
great time with me I could have done or
said something differently and usually
people end up thinking that well after
it's too late that's why I decided I
need to get this post out there and you
know the reason I waited is because I
the bike trip was already in motion I
was like here's what I'm doing about
excited to just come out and say all
right so you gotcha
so you post you went public with it
after you are already kind of well into
the solution yes I wanted to have a game
plan so people knew I don't want people
to worry I never want anyone to worry
about me that's the thing and so that's
why I've kind of mastered this this
there's a lot that happens behind a
smile really in anybody you know and um
I gotten pretty good at I'll I make
people laugh like that's my thing I love
making people are sure people are having
a good time and that they're safe around
me but um I made that post and then I
described the the plan for the journey
and the support was unbelievable that it
wasn't like I expected it would be like
private messages you know you're in my
thoughts and if there's anything I can
do you know stuff like that people were
like this is amazing I'm sharing this
and maybe other veterans will kind of
decide to do something yeah about it or
just try to take back some of that
purpose for themselves try to take on a
challenge well so when you're in that
moment you were in that darkest you know
that darkest moment what was it that
clicked in side of you to do something
about it like take me from that moment
to the moment of deciding that you're
gonna hang you know get a bike and ride
a bike and how this whole ride came
together yes I I'd been planning the
trip with a friend a friend I met
through a mutual friend of marine and we
talked about but I hadn't purchased my
bicycle yet and I was still really
struggling and on the fence about you
know actually going through with it
and I had an evening where I just I just
tend to stare at the wall sometimes for
a while and think about big stuff or
just what anything really and I get kind
of lost in some of that and I think I
just convinced myself that I think
people would be okay and that basically
it goes back to coming home without my
friend just I don't know if I deserve to
be here and I'm not even taking
advantage of the life that has been
gifted to me because of someone else's
sacrifice and it just really knows gnaws
at me it still does but it's better
having you know completed this mm-hmm
but I had kind of a a game plan for if
I'd gone through with with taking my
life and everything and it was a bit
elaborate but it was kind of like the
least one of the maybe the least
shocking kind of ways I just didn't want
to hurt anyone / or scar anybody yeah
you know so that night I was I was I was
right there I'll say that's like right
there and I ended up just falling asleep
and so the next day I was like that's it
that's I can't do one more night like
that I'm not gonna get through it I'm
not gonna get through it so I literally
just woke up and went and purchased my
bicycle the next day right to the bike
store yes and you had had so the plan
was the the plan was already in motion
to do a ride prior to that you just
hadn't taken any action on it yet right
i purchasing the bicycle was like the
the decision like that is a decision
maker and had you been a cyclist like he
had you've ridden a bike before no not
well not since ninth grade other than
just being a kids dog ever been no great
school was the last time I ridden a
bicycle so but it comes right back girly
does it I took the bicycle by the adage
is true
what you learn how to ride it like
riding a bike and everyone would say it
and I'm really good and then I got on it
I'm like okay that's why that exists it
really does come right back and um so I
took I got a Kona suture a steel frame
Kona Sutra mm-hmm from a bike shop in
Nashville called Halcyon and I went in a
few times didn't take it on a test ride
I was honestly I was nervous but I
didn't want them to know I was like no I
can't I don't really have time right now
I was just kind of looking around and I
was like I'm gonna fall like I had it
really bears myself it's intimidating to
go to into a bike shop when you don't
really know what's going on I remember
the first time I did that yeah it's it's
it's weird cuz you think everyone's an
expert and they're gonna like you know
if you got you're afraid to ask a stupid
question or whatever very much though
yeah I mean I mess up all the time and
make fun of myself all the time but I I
don't want to like sense staring wants
to sense what was the idea you were
gonna ride across the United States
already so okay so there was this grand
vision yes yep I just needed to get the
bike buy that bike yeah so I went in and
talked with one of the owners and she's
like do you want me to go on a test ride
with you and uh because she I think she
could tell I was really hesitant about
trying it and so we we did we got on the
bicycles and started going down the
street and it felt unbelievable it was
like unbelievable the the wind and the
work and all those feelings it's like
this is this is great I can do this not
only is this fun or whatever biking
physically I feel like I can really
physically do this that was a huge fear
of mine was do I start out on this and
then my physical limitations I don't
want to fail anything and I don't want
to commit to boot camp you could do it
well except with me with the injuries
and the pain and stuff yes yes with the
because I've had work chronic more like
worsening pain over the years so it's
it's worsening I've you know I've been
to the VA for MRIs and things like that
so they're working with me on trying to
yeah help it but it's been diagnosed as
chronic pain that's that has worsened
over the years
unfortunately so like hiking or
really long distance hiking everything
I just can't prescribe like pain meds
for that they offered I uh I made it a
point to not do the narcotics but they
offer you like oxy oh no for you I
believe it was the oxycodone but I I
asked specifically not for a narcotic
and they they gave me like two hundred
three hundred ibuprofen 800 milligram IV
profile which I just hardcore ibuprofen
yes the highest one you get in I only
take it when I absolutely have to you
because I like to know what's going on
with my body too so I try not to do
really pain meds because I will overdo
it as soon as I don't feel pain it's
like I feel like superwoman like I just
want to bust through every wall I can
find but and what did they ever you ever
prescribe like SSRIs like a
anti-depression medication awesome Balta
AHA cymbalta and I'd actually didn't
start taking it I went left on the bike
trip instead yeah and that was a really
good choice I think nothing there's
anything wrong with it it is supposed to
help with nerve pain and chronic pain
too so it made sense that they
prescribed it I just once I was out
there as I would felt wonderful free
time yes
yeah everything about the journey was
incredible so you go out on this test
ride and then you come back and you're
like alright I'm behind this is like how
did that work that's exactly what
happened we went out we just did some
road cycling and I I got ahead of her
real quick cuz I was starting honestly I
was starting to tear up I was so happy
of that I could do it mmm you know not
only just with the balance aspect but my
niece didn't her I mean it was only you
know a half a mile but my knees didn't
hurt at all and I'm the way I had a
position where the seat was slightly
lower my neck really didn't hurt I
wasn't real hunched you know like I'm
writing like I'm supposed to be but I
had to make some modifications to my
bicycle for my neck and um
I was just excited it's like I really
believe I can do this and then I bought
that thing I was like this is happening
and how long after you bought it did the
ride begin less than a month uh-huh
yes I really only trained for about
three weeks right by train I mean like
unweighted ten-mile rides I was like
yeah this you know this is a cool I did
a 50-mile Iran it's called the Natchez
Trace Parkway near South Nashville but
Nashville has this the music city bike
way it's like 30 miles long goes through
all the a lot of the parks it's
beautiful so I went out there and that's
how I trained I just wrote rode my bike
got used to it and you get like the
panniers and all that the idea is you're
gonna bring all your stuff right right
yeah it was a self supported run and
this is out little experience I had I
have always in still call them panniers
okay all the time they're paint they're
panniers that's my set tears it's I have
a hilariously small amount of experience
you know widget anyway that's a huge
factors that anyone can do it really
what I did honest to god anyone can do
what I did especially after coming out
of a major surgery having the physical
pain no experience whatsoever it's just
basically no training no no no training
or three weeks beforehand you hadn't
ridden a bike since you were 10 years
old yes
well ninth-grade a long time ago right a
lifetime ago several lifetimes ago and
and did you get like a tent and
everything like you just basically can't
you're gonna camp along the way and just
did you plot like spent a lot of time
figuring out the route and where you
want it to go and the route was already
preset as a route by the Adventure
Cycling Association it's called the
Transamerica trail and it originally
goes from Yorktown Virginia to Astoria
Oregon but in Pueblo Colorado it
branches off you can take what's called
the Western Express which is what I did
it takes you to San Francisco yes yeah I
really wanted to cross the Golden Gate
for the finish I just thought it'd be
really symbolic I'd never been there
just crossing bridges and new beginnings
not that whole mindset yeah when you
embarked upon this did you have a sense
that this was gonna be a mission not
just for yourself but to you know
connect with veterans along the way and
try to be you know available and of
assistance or did that develop over time
because you kind of had two bites at
this Apple right well yes it into yes
the a huge part of it was honoring the
friends I lost overseas and definitely
post-war healing for me I needed to do
something that's kind of a bit of a Hail
Mary trip you know I was kind of my rock
bottom I I believe it was my rock bottom
I think I was starting to feel some of
the things that some of my friends had
been feeling and I'd lost a couple of
friends to suicide also so and it was
definitely I wanted to not only help
myself but help others in different ways
I wanted to be a little more vocal about
some of the stuff I was dealing with and
I just I didn't think there was any way
I could be alone in it you know and then
just the fact that I'd lost friends the
suicide I wanted to talk more about that
too because I understood that downward
spiral and the darkness and how it just
swoops in and sweeps you off your feet
yeah well what's interesting about that
is that typically people that embark
upon these kind of adventures they're
you know they had their lowest moment or
their darkest moment and then there's
the healing period and then they become
whole and then they decide okay now I'm
gonna share it whether that means riding
their bike across the country or
starting a non-profit or whatever
there's kind of a you know that there's
a period of time that elapses in between
those two things and for you they're
like right on top of each other yeah
like so you're very close to that dark
moment but you're already like you're
not like just in the solution you're
already you're already in the advocacy
role as well at the same time yes the
the darkness and the light kind of it
was it was gonna be one or the other
when I bought that bicycle and I chose
to do the bicycle thing and and so I
posted on Facebook about it and then I
documented it as I went made it public I
like
added pressure of people following and
it fueled me the support and
encouragement and everything I mean yeah
some people I've sure there's like
doubters and stuff or like but that's
like that's totally fine that's happened
to me my whole life I I encourage it
yeah like it's fine
yeah so you saw your blog posting on
Facebook and you're very public about
this so tell me about some of the
experiences that you had connecting with
veterans along the way they there were
many veterans I ran into and it was
amazing and none of almost none of them
were planned it also wasn't like I'm
gonna go to this VFW and and and they
know I'm coming and I'm gonna talk to
them and there's gonna they're waiting
for me they're there I wanted to go to
more VFW's there weren't a lot on the
route so I was able to go to some and
they were awesome they didn't really
know I was coming I didn't really
broadcast it in that way I was just I
kind of wanted it to be a little more
private but also let people in on it
kind of a thing rather than the big
spotlight thing because I'm actually
really not used to that sort of thing
you know I could I am a private person
and so I guess I sought out veterans in
the towns that would go through how did
you find him it just happened literally
I have countless experiences with
veterans I have to write about them all
I included a bunch of my blog but
there's so many more than that they were
for us being such a small percent of the
population it felt like we were just
everywhere it's almost like they found
me or something like I needed I needed
to find them and vice versa or something
it just it really was that random and
which I think made it way more beautiful
and special and uh having it unplanned I
think resulted in maybe a deeper
connection with it being so spontaneous
and and tell me about what it's you know
what transpires when you make that
connection like how is that how and why
is that healing not just for you but for
the other person
I I think once you discover that each
other is a veteran you kind of start in
this this different place I think where
you get to skip past a bunch of stuff
and like the small talk thing or
sometimes it takes people years to get
kind of close like that and you can just
almost dive into each other you don't
have to skim the surface you just dive
into the conversation you you could just
start making fun of each other you could
pick out you know each other has the
same sense of humor a similar mindsets I
think of a lot of us share the same
qualities when we join like wanting to
the selfless service and the and all
that sort of aspect and they're so you
already kind of know who the person is
deep down a little bit and then you can
build from from there and the sense of
humor really is the best part I mean
sitting there for a half-hour and joking
on each other is therapy like I love
that ha so wasn't necessarily about
making a point of bringing up PTSD as it
was just organically connecting with
these people the the topic almost always
got brought up and if it didn't I you
know I tried to talk about some of the
stuff I was going through and why I was
doing what I was doing I always made it
a point to because really I more than
anything I was asked like what are you
doing why and right of course and if I
didn't I would I would go and do it
eventually after letting them and so
what did you say I mean what is the
response of that like I'm dealing with
PTSD and I was at a very dark moment and
now I'm doing this to try to reclaim my
life right this is basically what I
would say I I explained that it had kind
of come to a head some of the guilt and
depression and some of the things I
needed to do something to kind of prove
to myself that I wanted and deserve to
be here I needed a new big challenge to
prove I was still capable of something
like this and it was very important to
me to tell the friends I lost by living
instead of isolating and not wanting to
be here and then having lost friends to
suicide knowing there's 22 a day
that are doing this and that I was so
close myself it was kind of a Tet like a
personal intimate testimony to - that -
yeah and a lot of people didn't know
that we were losing 22 veterans a day
it's a lot it's a lot it's it's so many
I mean you fight so hard to get back and
I would describe as the the war inside
is just totally different than the ones
we were trained to win mm-hmm you know
yeah very very well trained to fight the
war without not so well-trained to
combat the world within and the war
within doesn't go away until it's
confronted does it no and you can you
can beat it to death here in your own
head you could fuel it within seconds
over weeks without knowing well all
those skills that you learn in the
military work at cross-purposes with
what what's required of you to actually
get to the other side mm-hmm right so
there has to be confusing it can be
there's definitely an internal conflict
as the light in the darkness and what to
say what not to say who you want to let
it in in what ways and I don't know but
on the trip the more one of the biggest
factors for my heat my personal healing
was talking to other veterans and I
think that really is like one of the
biggest things we can do for ourselves
is to seek out other veterans spend time
whatever that entails like I said you
could just make fun of each other and
that's therapy sometimes you know yeah I
mean I'm somebody who's in long I've
been in recovery for a long time and you
know a core aspect of that is getting
together with other you know alcoholics
and addicts and you have that shorthand
and there's that community and there's
that connectivity and that
accountability that helps people not
just get sober but but stay sober and
that's like the most important community
to me and my long-term well-being
without that I don't know if I would be
here
so why would it be any different for
what you're going through and what's
required for you to heal and to help
others heal yes there's a loss people
bond I think through struggle and
tragedy more powerfully than anything
mm-hmm I think and you have a collective
experience that a lot of people can't
relate to you know that only you truly
understand mm-hmm yeah and even more so
it does come down to individual veterans
too and their struggles and issues very
person-to-person which is why it's hard
to decipher a one solution to all this
you know so yeah it all gets thrown
under the umbrella of PTSD but you know
you could be you know somebody who
suffered a sexual abuse situation or
childhood abuse or you could have you
know been on a deployment where your
best friend gets blown up by an you know
an AED or something like that like those
all fall under that umbrella but those
are all very different things they're
all traumas mm-hmm but I would imagine
you know the specifics are important in
terms of how you move forward right yeah
the experiences are all there they all
vary and it's almost like different
wounds similar scars and I don't know
when you get around people that you've
been through something similar with so
much can go unspoken like you don't have
to dive into the the darkest things to
relate and especially if you don't focus
on comparing if you focus on relating
mm-hmm and listening what were some of
the more profound or impactful
encounters that you had with veterans
along the way like others are a
particular one that stands out yes
they're either several actually and I
would say specifically Vietnam veterans
the insight I gained from them was mind
blowing they've been dealing with things
a lot longer and they didn't stop
fighting when they came home like when
they got
back I mean I can't imagine that well I
got a welcome home ceremony you know I
can't imagine going through something
like that and then coming back to that
and they worked so hard to pave the way
for my generation of combat veterans and
so basically the consensus is it done
getting easier you just need to figure
out ways to deal with it and not not
tough it out but just know that it
probably or might not get easier and
have that in mind and just kind of work
with it you know don't stop trying to
mmm to help yourself
and they're all close they're pretty
I think tight-knit or they try to stay
in contact I did meet a few along the
way that they don't go to anything
militarily they do stay at home quite a
bit and honestly from from what they
told me that does that is a big problem
for them too I think it's just it just
comes down to seeking out each other
putting the effort into yeah just
talking to each other about it did you
meet anybody that you were deployed with
or anybody that was in Tikrit when you
were there on my journey yeah no no
everyone I deploy with was in Ohio
so my route was Virginia Kentucky
Illinois Kansas Colorado Utah Nevada in
California it was so far this is the
hardest part of the ride well I I don't
mean to every country or every part of
the country presented totally different
challenges like the the Appalachians
starting east to west just starting
right into the Appalachians right so
you're going he's gonna win the whole
time so yes man apart for yourself from
the get-go I decided to go east to west
yes the the headwind was especially in
the Rocky Mountains that the headwind
was relentless and then you would press
well then the mountains were difficult
alone but then you would start to crest
near like oh my gosh it's the summit and
then a huge headwind and you almost like
go backward but yeah the head ones
for a challenge for sure but um honestly
I think the biggest threat along the way
it wasn't people like everyone thought
it would be it was the heat I feel like
the heat was this little sneaky ninja
that in the Ozarks it was the heat the
humidity was a humidity yeah just
yesterday I had two women in here who
are endurance athletes and one of whom
did Ram Race Across America like her and
a teammate they did it what 8 days I
think I did yeah and eight days there
across America and she was saying that
the hardest part was it was the Ozarks
right Appalachians or the Ozarks I think
it I think of the Ozark she was like
yeah when the Rockies were hard but like
the Ozarks or like super hard I mean
they go west east so they're coming up
the other side from where you wrote and
I'm sure it wasn't the same route but
she was saying yeah they were steeper
and windy and like brutal yeah they just
come out of nowhere then like I must
have been just super geographically
challenged I thought after the
Appalachians
it was just gonna flatten out for me and
I was super excited and that's the Ozark
started so when I hit Kansas that
everyone told me well by everyone I mean
quite a few people told me that I would
hate Kansas it's boring you can see as
far as you know you can't I loved Kansas
after the Appalachians and the Ozarks it
was it was like a dream it was amazing
know many days yeah yes and the straight
line it's great you could just kind of
let your mind race instead instead of
more like going crazy it's just a steady
did you listen to music or audiobooks or
yes you did yeah I listen to music every
day uh-huh on the trickier roads I'd
leave like my left ear but out right you
know so I can hear the cars and
everything but music was huge on this
thing my playlist was super random and
but different songs were perfect with
different Cadence's and intensities and
then of course just with the mood my
floor my thoughts were at that day that
almost like I would just pick to cater
to that so I can't I can't listen to
music for long periods of time like I
need something
to focus my brain on mm-hmm so listen to
podcasts or audiobooks or something like
that I said oh another thing is the
sounds of nature were amazing and if I
knew I'd be in a heavily wooded area or
something like that I would just turn it
off and just listen you can just hear
your tires on the pavement and then all
the all the sounds around you it was
just wonderful and how did you deal with
food I mean were you ever in a situation
where the next place to get something to
eat was too far away or did you make
sure you have enough packed with you all
the time
yes I always carried three days of food
on me and I mainly took oatmeal oatmeal
was huge for energy and everything it's
almost like my body knew exactly what to
do with it and I could just go and go
and go with oatmeal so I had like my
cook set and my food bananas were
helpful but they're heavy yeah but yeah
I would carry three days of food on me
just in case and did you ever come when
you would come into a city would you be
like I'm going to I'm getting a hotel
room I'm gonna take a shower yes yeah
yes I my I think my favorite part one at
night was the camping no like that was
my very favorite was to end the day and
just sleep under the stars and listen to
everything I just cycled through and the
air and everything I don't know I loved
roughing it so much that was a huge plus
for the trip for me so you get into
Colorado and then you have an
unfortunate encounter with a truck yes
what happened I was it was the first day
into the Rocky Mountains so I was coming
up on my first incline in the Rockies
after going through Kansas and I was on
a curve and this this big black truck
came over he was just starting to come
over and more and more so I went over
but there really wasn't a shoulder it
was just saying
and so I was you know behind me behind I
mean I watched my route rearview like a
hawk - so he just kept veering right
very right so I did - and I went off the
road went into the sand and then fell
back into the lane and just missed his
train he was pulling a trail
so I just missed his trailer and then
leaned in the lane there was a car
tailgating the truck that didn't see me
they were so close threw my arm up real
quick and they swerved around my head
basically it was so loud the sound of
the tired when I'm at a red light and
someone's goofing off and they peel out
I still like you know that sound is so
distinct and it was so piercing and um
so the night before I ran into have you
heard of Team Rubicon yeah they're
they're much bigger now they're awesome
a lot of veterans mostly veterans are in
there and they were working on a project
locally there had been some fires and
then mudslides and then flooding so they
were clearing up some of the rivers and
creeks and everything and they were
working down the hill that day and they
heard the tires squeal Wow they're like
we wonder why there wasn't a crash
afterward and I was like oh that was me
not getting run over an over deal but I
partially tore my PCL ligament in my
knee and on I stayed in Colorado Springs
for like two weeks trying to recover
because I didn't want to go I wanted to
continue yeah so it just wasn't getting
better I waited I went to the VA a
couple times of course they're like
change your socks take motor and drink
water you know three days tops
you know we're back in the cave so I did
everything right I elevated I sill the
all that stuff so I got on my bicycle
after two weeks flat ground no weight
and it swelled right up and I knew it
was it wasn't good so I ended up going
back to Nashville I had to let it heal
then over the winter and then I had to
wait for a winter to end because there
Aki mountains I was starting literally
back into my first mountain the day I
started back so um the winners last a
lot longer at the top of the yeah some
it's so I had to wait till let's see I
started back on June 2nd from pueblo so
I went back slightly on the route like a
day or two back and Pueblo was very
special to me that they actually had
ascend
they felt bad it happened in their state
and I was like huh one batch don't you
yeah it was oh I just was mind blowing
really the whole trip really was the
kindness it was nuts and they had a
send-off there and the there's a bike
shop there a Great Divide and they they
tuned my bike up for free for me and
everything and they there was a group of
cyclist that rode with me that first day
back back out it's cool it was really
odd the support was incredible it really
fueled me to it's like I definitely
finishing this that first day back there
was an incline and I knew that would
kind of set the tone and I busted up
that thing I could oh yeah I got that it
was so liberating to come off there's
nothing worse than being athletic or in
the middle of something like that and
having an injury and going through that
recovery that's what kind of brought
things to a head to begin with I was
like cool another vicious cycle I made
it halfway just over halfway and but I'm
like no no that not at this time I'm
like you have to finish what you start
when you had to go back home and nurse
that injury how did you prevent yourself
from succumbing to another vicious cycle
and falling into a depression and
emotional eating and you know how did
you put the brakes on on basically
falling prey to what had handicapped you
previously I think the difference this
time was that I let people in and I had
this support system in place and there
were all these people that were
encouraging me that I that I was making
a difference for them also that I was
inspiring them and answering their
messages I would message with probably a
dozen maybe two dozen vets a day like
you know hey this is inspiring me to be
more active or I'm gonna start this
thing I'm gonna hike this and do that
and like I read your story and like what
you're amazing I'm like no I'm just you
can do trust me you can do it and so I
was having all these conversations and
interactions with other veterans through
my Facebook message or Facebook page and
all these peopIe
possibly consider not continuing this
time and so I actually had an army
buddy of mine come down for a couple
weeks and help me train and get kind of
back on after it had been after I'd
nursed it for a while he helped me get
back on track and that was super helpful
I just made sure I did everything right
I documented my recovery and everything
I think that pressure really really
helps me I like to kind of be under
pressure yeah the pressure and and being
a member of a community that was quickly
growing and of which you were you know
basically the hub with all these folks
don't get made me feel awesome I mean I
love knowing I'm making some kind of
difference so finishing what I started
was a no-brainer to me I was gonna do
whatever it took to do it I was like I'm
gonna have to I mean it would take me
probably losing a leg to know it even
then even then I mean whatever it took I
couldn't let these people down or myself
I was like no I'm regaining this lust
for life you know I can feel it
happening I can feel the healing
happening and um so that was really my
that was the difference this time really
is that I let people in and then it
became this totally different cycle
mm-hmm beautiful awesome and the idea
was I want to connect with America this
country that you know basically I went
overseas to serve I want to get to know
the people that live here what else did
you learn about our country with the you
know you you're connecting with all
these veterans but what did you not
expect to discover like surprised you
the the kindness and warmth surprised me
in that another thing that was kind of
bumming me out quite a lot actually is
just how divided everything feels
anymore no one's looking for reasons to
like each other and it just feels like
everyone just kind of hated each other
and I'm especially over the last couple
years with the media social media stuff
like that is all this negativity all the
time and you already kind of feel
alienated enough and then to kind of
come back to a society where no one's
really getting along you know it is a
bummer and that definitely contributed
to
you know me wanting to reconnect with
the country and experience people again
surprise was that the the warmth was
overwhelming from east to west mm-hmm
yeah I feel like we are very divided
right now and we're sitting here the day
after midterm elections if you're on
Twitter or Facebook or on social media
in general if you're watching the news
it can be depressing and dire to come
into the sense of just how differently
so many people see the world and and how
we're unable to have healthy
communication about these things but
when you know I go out into communities
it doesn't reflect what you're seeing on
Twitter you know what I mean like right
when you're with people in person one on
one then I realize maybe we're not
really as divided as it appears or that
picture that's being painted perhaps
isn't as accurate as reality yeah when
you're sitting in front of the person
there's almost like a little more
respect is required you know and I think
people tend to maybe share other
people's words and thoughts on social
media they're not having to formulate
their own and really think through why
they're heated or emotionally charged
about things really yeah that sort of
lines up I'm gonna post this and then
they lose friends or or people get
offended and you know it is a problem
reconnecting with people in person is is
completely different when you're sitting
there with someone like you want to give
them their chance to talk and vice versa
it's it's just a lot harder to be rude
and dismissive in person to I mean I
think people want to get deep down they
want to get along and be happy with
themselves and ever I would think so I
just felt like I said very divided and
negative so I wanted to get away from
that too
so I didn't really spend hardly any time
on social media I would do a blog post
maybe once every three weeks or
something I I could have done way more I
would get messages like are you alive
like right
you can you say something you know I
want to know how this went like I'm
sorry it takes me a while to get my
stuff together plus I I tried not to be
on there too much but still enough where
people know what I'm doing and things
but it was a really nice experience
detaching from all that and I miss it I
do kind of miss just kind of being out
there I mean I miss it very much that's
and I was gonna tell you well we hadn't
talked about the the remainder of the
trip yet but coming home is is a lot
like coming back from a deployment -
yeah that was I was curious about that
because now you've done another huge
adventure right and you have a react
LeMay ssin period different from
returning from deployment but also the
prospect of having some kind of big
letdown and becoming depressed would be
if not expected normal right so I
imagine you were there was some fear
like I was gonna a my gonna have that
experience again that's exactly what
happened well people asked me what I was
most afraid of about it and it was
finishing my honest answer was always
finishing then what you know square one
and just another vicious cycle I was
that was my biggest fear and so I
decided during my recovery I really put
together an idea for a veteran program
and nonprofit that I'm I'm starting in
nashville taking veterans out in nature
detaching together waypoint that's right
yes yeah yes so uh so you could return
with this mission of basically paying
forward the experience that you had
that's exactly what I want and need to
do is I would always ask people in the
trip what can i what can I ever do to
thank you or pay you and I said just pay
you know continue it the kindness that's
exactly what I'm gonna do it that's
exactly what I've been missing there was
that New York Times article that shared
your story and the story of a number
know the number of other veterans who
have had similar experiences to your own
they mentioned this organization called
warrior expeditions or right so some guy
who like basically had the same epiphany
that you had and it's like look we need
to get these guys home and get them out
of nature and their stories about
veterans coming home and walking the
Appalachian Trail or just really having
that quiet - that silence that you know
ability to phase themselves back into a
sense of normalcy slowly and over time
that I think we lack and as I recall
there was a story in there about how
that used to be like I can't remember
where it was maybe you remember that
used to be something that was kind of
structured like when I went to like the
these soldiers would literally walk from
wherever their battlefield was back to
wherever they lived and it could be take
weeks or something like that in that
space allowed them to decompress
sufficiently to ward off some of these
you know PTSD symptoms but when you just
get on a plane you know one day you're
in Tikrit in the next day you're in Ohio
you know it's got to be super weird like
what just happened yeah it's so quick so
yeah taking the time and consciously
tackling some of the things getting away
from the stimuli daily all these little
daily decisions and these little mundane
things we worry about every day just
eliminating those from the equation you
can really do not only soul-searching
but um you can kind of hash through a
lot like what what do I really need to
be thinking about all the time because
it simplifies your life and so you can
you can also tackle big things to
simplify your thought processes their
daily thought processes like on the road
it was so simple you you know what you
have to do you have to cycle this day
and then you plan where you end and then
you have a plan for food and water and
you have everything you need on your
bike and you don't need anything from
anybody so you get to enjoy the
experience of the day and the experience
of meeting the people you know and then
you're happy
and yet we create these lies that are so
complicated we created these
complications because we delude
ourselves into thinking that's what's
gonna make us happy but it's actually
only when we strip away all of that and
get back to kind of the bare necessities
yeah I got home and I didn't even yeah I
still don't know what exactly how to
dress myself yet I'm still wearing like
the same four things
uh-huh even today wearing your cycling
kit right now yes yes I know I had to I
had to but yes I have worn this
otherwise so it's just yeah you just
kind of you don't want to add all that
back if anything you want to go back out
there to where it's normal and I'm
another reason this was so helpful is it
Italy justified that hyper-vigilance
having to watch everything and it's so
quick pace and any little thing like a
chipmunk could end you out there huh on
a decline it's it's funny but also it's
true like a pine cone literally you
could lose control and you know coming
down a mountain a gust of wind things
like that like you have to constantly be
on point you know watching every can you
have to be in the military yes yeah it
was really nice to conjure all that back
up and those skill sets
I'm just knowing that they were still in
place and that it was an environment
where I could use them and not feel
weird or silly well I think in the wake
of this adventure you know on this issue
of you know how are you gonna you know
this fear of completing it and is this
gonna set in motion another you know
vicious cycle that you're gonna have to
overcome you know the the post you know
elation experience of coming down back
to earth and reintegrating yourself back
into your life the distinguishing thing
the the difference is that this was part
of a healing process right like you're
healing as you go by connecting with
these veterans by connecting with your
body by connecting with nature so when
you think back on this bike ride is it
the adventure aspect of it is it the
challenge aspect of doing something that
was very difficult and maybe you thought
you couldn't do was it the connecting
with the
veterans and just Americans in general
what aspect of that do you think has
been the most impactful on your healing
process
all right just all of those things
together well the easy answer would be
all of it and the truest answer would be
all of it but uh I really feel that III
wasn't okay and and I'm really no good
to anyone unless I'm good to go and this
the reconnecting like you said with your
body with nature and with people it I
think it just really takes all all three
of those things that's why I want to do
this next step and I felt like my life
was changed forever in a really good way
from east to west I just I like to
relive some of the days randomly
throughout my day and I just I want to
facilitate like smaller versions of of
what I like you know experience
firsthand this healing I want to help
other veterans get a sense of that or at
least introduce them to it I think
that's a worthy that's a worthy venture
you know we just you know we like to say
we support the troops thank you for your
service but we don't do very much in
terms of supporting those troops once
they come home and part of that is the
government's responsibility and part of
that is our responsibility as a
community of civilians and how we
interact with veterans and how we
support them and making sure that these
services are readily available to the
veterans in need and that an environment
is created in which they feel
comfortable availing themselves of the
right because the statistics are
shocking 22 a day take their life how
many how many are thinking about it how
many have
failed suicide attempts how many are
depressed how many are over medicated
you know I mean the numbers have to be
astonishing right the Veterans
Administration can't solve all of these
problems and we as a culture need to do
a better job of raising awareness about
what's going on and finding solutions
supportive solutions to addressing and
solving this very big issue yeah I I
think I've said in my blog I feel like
we have a responsibility to ourselves
and each other and our fallen you know
to help each other pick each other up
and fight through this war inside that
we're all facing just maybe lighter or
darker and different different times for
the individual but it really I think
comes down to us helping each other I
think the people best equipped to help
us are us and I think people want to
help but don't really know how and a lot
of times we don't know what to tell them
we don't know yeah it's awkward from as
somebody who's a civilian and you
encounter a veteran you don't really
know what to say you know that you don't
really understand their situation you
want to say the right thing and you
don't know what that is so you say thank
you for your service and then there's
like okay are we done
you know what do I say now right yes
yeah it's awkward it's weird right I'm
sure you have this all the time yeah I
always say thank you for your support
- I mean without without that support
and encouragement and that back and
forth
that's it never gets old you know to
hear thank you even though we we don't
feel we're deserving of the thanks a lot
of the times or we kind of shy away from
the compliment sir the word hero or
anything like that you know
humility is you know we think about the
people we lost when when we hear that
stuff and sometimes it's just better
just say thank you and thank you for
your support because you know like I
said we had a welcome home when we got
back if that wasn't in place who knows
how
myself for my friends are right there
anymore my generation would yeah yeah
yeah do you think that the movies get it
right like whether it's Hurt Locker or
did you see thank you for your service
did you see that mouth have you seen
that one yeah you know I'm just curious
as to whether you think that that
Hollywood accurately reflects that
experience or whether it's a you know a
glossed over version or if there is a
show or a movie that that got it right
what that would be
I thought Hurt Locker was very well done
I really did and I think that I think
they definitely try to be as accurate as
they can and they have to I think clam
it up for the audience but for me the
the parts that get me in the movies is
the the coming back and that coming home
mm-hmm that's I have a classic Jon
Voight coming home from Vietnam you
should see that movie okay I will I will
look is what I invited you sir no yeah
no no I'm making a mental note because I
should see a movie about a Vietnam
veteran coming home I've spoken with so
many Vietnam veterans they probably give
me some insight in this least I could do
after all they've given me so yeah
speaking of which home is the heart I
think for me it was yeah weirdest part
like you'll never be the same again the
child is lost that or that innocent I
don't know there's so much that could be
attributed to it but you know you
probably never be the same again or
maybe really a lot less with a lot fewer
people things like that it was cool in
researching your story and looking on
your Facebook page and your blog and and
seeing a couple videos my favorite is
the I assume they're Vietnam veterans
the vets who are on motorcycles who
escorted you down to the Golden Gate
Bridge
yes that was super cool that that was
that day was amazing they were the the
Legion Riders the American Legion Riders
and I was very last minute short notice
and they came out there I went to the
world the War Memorial Museum downtown
San Francisco and
and met a guy who's the chair there and
then he and a commander from one of the
American Legion Post there made a couple
calls and said hey we got this you know
combat veteran she's cycling across
America she's finishing you guys want to
come out and you know be there and they
did they totally showed up it it was
mind-blowing the the last minute support
like that just people hearing about it
and be like we're there we're just there
and I'm I try to tell as many better as
possible that we do have a family out
there that's bigger than any one of us
can ever imagine I never imagined that I
would have that outpouring of support
like that you know and after after
moving States and losing touch people
not seeking out veteran organizations
and not talking to other veterans for a
while I totally forgot about that
you know and I just remember we all met
at the the north end of the bridge and
crossed into San Francisco so I was in
the bike lane on the Golden Gate and
then they were in the regular lanes
because I couldn't be there and they
couldn't be here so and they were just
cranking there uh-oh it's just sounded
thunder is like this thunderous
wonderful thing in so we crossed the the
bridge and while I was on there I was
just thinking to myself like that this
is it you know this is this is the
finish line and I just started thinking
about all the support I gotten and it
really took me over I mean I I was
halfway down the bridge where the the
arches the cables kind of went were at
their lowest and I caught a glimpse of
the Pacific and I it was overwhelming
and so afterward we we went through
parts of San Francisco it which is very
hilly city yes I didn't oh I was I was
very fatigued I was like I can't mess
this up the last day that's that's
ridiculous there I get it together but
um and you made a promise that you were
never gonna walk your bike right yes
yeah I never once walked my bike on the
trip that is something I just did for me
it wasn't prove anything that you know
to anyone but myself I just that's
something I real
to do and I stuck to it and actually I
did walk it across the sand of the
Pacific ha ha but yeah when you have
were you at the Presidio or were you at
Ocean Ocean Beach it was Ocean Beach
right which is it really love well it's
a it's a long beach but it's also a very
wide beach and so I got to the stairs
and they they were all in the sand I
went down the stairs my bike I had all
my stuff on there is heavy you know and
the bike was just sinking and I was
pushing my bicycle through the sand and
it it was very diff it was very
difficult and I was kind of coming up on
some muscle like 100 yards from the
beach and you're like I'm gonna make it
it was like 800 walk in my defense but
my legs were I mean they were hit muscle
for after the inclines and everything
and I just I looked down at my feet and
I equated kind of my shoes in the sand
of might my boots in the scene overseas
and I remember that's when I felt like
the most capable that's when I felt the
most alive and something just kind of
happened I kind of got this second win a
second one that could sink ships is I
did my thing and and everyone was just
yelling you got this you know and I
heard all those voices and I just it all
came together in my head and honestly I
was that close to muscle failure like no
one knows but me until until now but it
took that and something just couldn't I
just oh I mean I don't know if I can
swear but you can swear I got hauled ass
nothing that's very mild to but um I
just pushed and I got to the shore and
when I walked in the water and I kind of
felt the the waves rush around my ankles
it was like I felt everything I felt
everyone everyone we'd lost everyone
that supported me everyone that was
there and couldn't be there
I just felt them I I just really felt
deep down in my soul that I'd made them
proud that that it was a mission
accomplished
and yeah and a mission accomplished for
yourself but more importantly a mission
that represented
healing for other people as well yes
yeah yeah I mean you can take back
control of your life and your happiness
I mean we have to we have to take
control if you're not gonna do it no
one's gonna do it no no no people want
to do it for you but they don't know how
you're the only one that knows exactly
how to do it one of the things I like
that you said was that in the military
you're you're trained to believe that
the m16 becomes an extension of your arm
right and that the bike that became yes
the the extension of your arm for you
like he'd swapped one for the other but
it has that equal you know that that are
equal importance to you yes when the day
I purchased it I I got a little choked
I've been talking a lot about crying but
I'm not a big crier I want to go on the
record to say but I did get a little
choked up when I bought that bike
secretly I just I put my hand on the
saddle and I was thinking about that
connection you know with my m16 and it's
like that I relied on that it relied on
me you keep it clean it keeps you alive
and you now I have my bicycle and it's
gonna get me from one side of the
country or the other and who knows
what's gonna happen in between and it's
just me and my bike you know and it was
really a special connection I don't know
I we I knew we'd go through so much
together already like I was already
thinking way ahead to all the
possibilities and the elements and all
that stuff and then at the end there
having it with me that whole time having
been through everything we'd been
through all the inclines and then
tornado in Kansas and oh yeah you just
glossed over that oh it's not going
through a tornado there was a tornado
warning that okay it hit very close I
didn't distort why I hadn't a storm
drain for part of it and then ended up
in an element and a bit well not being
an unused elementary school uh-huh I've
ran into this lady who had a key and I'm
like do you know where I should probably
go for this tornado warnings I was just
going to sleep under that awning at the
city
park it's just like I happen to have a
key to this elementary school and she
let me in there and I hid under the
foundation oh my god I found an old
piece there was no there was no tornado
after all no it touched down or by Wow
yes oh yeah it was coming ha ha
fortunately and I found this old piano
and played Mary a little lamb till it
got really bad and like okay I'm gonna
go hide under the building so I don't
know
I loved amusing myself out there kind of
have to was there a moment where during
the ride when you realize like oh this
is working like was there a tipping
point we were like oh this is healing
like this is gonna be profound for me or
was it just in the completion of it no
one
it was totally throughout yeah well guys
the the town that we started out it was
a York town there was this restaurant
the Beachcomber restaurant and we just
randomly met we just walked in and
randomly met these people and all the
staff and the guests in there they all
came out and took a picture with me and
just from day one it was like that
people wanted to know and get on board
and everything the healing they were I
mean there were several things that
happen throughout that made a big
difference
um there were a couple instances where I
was genuinely worried that I was gonna
make it the Ozarks I had a very scary
day where I I was running low on water
and uh I'd rationed it but it was so hot
I mean it was a hundred eight but the
feels-like was in the one teens that day
I took a screenshot on my phone like
this isn't real life I was screaming at
Nats like I thought I was losing my mind
I definitely had heat exhaustion for
sure and I poured what was left in my
water over my head and smacked myself in
the face a few times literally and I was
just yelling at myself as I got you know
to this next time made it to the next
town honestly I really was worried about
making it that day and when I got there
I can't wipe the smile off my face even
now just knowing I'd been through that
and made it through and that I made it
to that town it was the most
exhilarating rush ever and then I got
sad thing he's really gonna take
this for me to feel that you know like
can't I just feel that after like a riot
photography yeah like you got to turn it
up to 11 like I just defer my toast
today that's awesome yeah it's like is
it really going to take this but um that
really was a that was very exhilarating
that I could still the the climbs the
climbs up the mountains there was one
called
that came out of haters gap it's called
and appropriately named and it was a
three point eight miles but only three
point eight miles long was a 1500 foot
climb so it was mm-hmm well I'm not
straight up I don't exaggerate but I
mean it was really intense climb and it
was the first big climb like that and um
I did not stop or walk once and I think
that's when I first realized physically
like I can make my mind control my body
again instead of the other way around
you know I was getting so down about my
physical limitations yeah and um that's
cute and it's like my god I just
destroyed myself and I feel great and I
don't hurt like it was a cycling is
beautiful like that I mean even if you
have these ailments or limitations or
whatever it's no impact and it's lighter
on you even even when you're doing stuff
like that I mean you can work through
that sort of pain where it doesn't
become overwhelming and you fail and so
much of the the climbs were mental so I
had to dig into the mental and with me
sometimes if it gets extremely difficult
I'll just start cracking up like just
because of how preposterous how
ludicrous the situation is and I'm doing
it and it just cracks me up and that
gives me my own second win in a way
uh-huh
and um so these things would happen on
these inclines the I describe them is
like a death and a rebirth you kind of
kill yourself going up and then you it's
like a reincarnation on the way down or
something I said the the inclines are
littered with discarded demons and then
the declines of tears of liberation like
that's exactly how I felt I was like I'm
gonna I'm just gonna use my demon star
in my wings
here how is your how is your pain now
it's now that I'm not cycling every day
it's creeping in so I'm sorry keeps it
at bay it does yeah you build some
muscle like a muscle base you know you
don't have to use heavy weights if
someone's struggling with a lot of
chronic pain and joint issues or muscle
issues cycling really is a great way to
stay active and everything without
overexerting or further injuring
yourself and building that muscle base
slowly what is your relationship with
cycling gonna look like now oh well I
miss it I love it I I don't want to go
so far as to say I get it because I have
only been doing it for so long I don't
want it like people have been doing this
their whole lives and I say they get it
you know there's a reason I'm starting
to fully understand the therapy it's
very therapeutic I'm really starting to
appreciate and comprehend the healing
and the push that comes with it and that
you get that solitude while being active
so it's like the healthiest way to
really kind of take some time for
yourself and and take in nature and know
you should like think about starting
like a century ride for veterans or you
know trying to interview cycling to
veteran I mean I presume you've already
thought about these things with the
venture that you're launching but one
for one of the activities cyclopia I
love the idea of a century ride because
that I mean I did one century right on
my trip and I just felt like Wonder
Woman or something you know I was just
seeing those triple digits there are
some places around Nashville I could do
that or really anywhere I'm I'm looking
into doing some outings you know all
over the country I know there's one in
particular this one Pass I went over in
Colorado called monarch Pass it was the
highest point on the route and that was
a doozy and that view at the top was
just breathtaking what was left of your
breath
airs a little thin up there but it just
sucks the rest out of you it's literally
breathtaking this view and there's a
gondola that takes you to the very tip
of it
I would love to take a group of veterans
up and over that thing that that would
be wonderful for them and for me to you
it yeah but um I was well as far as the
healing I would say the the handful of
days where I didn't know if I was gonna
make it and then the people it was the
people and not just veterans just
everybody it was everybody I don't think
I really had a negative encounter with
someone I met while on the journey that
I can think of a no moment where you
thought you were unsafe or there might
there was one moment I was going to
arrive at what I thought was a
campground and it ended up really just
being a trailhead with a picnic table
and I was like okay I guess I'll find a
little patch of flatland and it was a
very remote side road that no one should
be back like a meth lab back there or
something no what will this SUV like
super sketchy SUV went by and I was
pretty beat up and everything and I got
a bad feeling about it so they started
to circle around to a main road to come
back around and I took off on my bike
through the woods to this other road and
cut through to this other road continued
on my route so I like totally lost him
but they were definitely coming back
probably to see if I was the only one
there which I was and having traveled a
lot or part of it alone everyone was
asking you know do you carry a handgun
or a gun I didn't I didn't actually
carry one I had pepper spray in two
knives and so the pepper spray would
slow them down and then if I absolutely
have to use my knife I totally know how
you know but um I didn't even come close
you can avoid a lot of situations
honestly if you with forethought really
and especially um probably from I
definitely have the military to thank
for thinking like that and I love that
came in handy because I did I did avoid
a lot of things too just by cutting
cutting conversations short or not going
in somewhere getting out of somewhere
that hyper-efficient whining comes into
play because all I mean I read you know
body language facial expressions
inflection voice
is all that comes into play so it really
did come in handy and I loved that I had
to use it it's cool that that the ride
ended up getting a bunch of attention
too because when I first heard about it
I thought oh well this must have been
something you planned for a long time
and there was a whole bunch of energy
about what you were going to do before
you started but it's like no you just
bought a bike like basically started
riding it and and you know you've
generated all this interest out of what
you've done bicycling magazine wrote a
great article there was the New York
Times thing and a you know a bunch of
stuff out there if you just poke her on
the internet and those cool videos from
the news the news crews that were there
when you finished in San Francisco
yes yeah so it must be wild for you
because you were kind of just doing this
for your own personal healing right it
was it was definitely wild for me I
wasn't I wasn't doing it for any kind of
spotlight really I actually didn't even
know really how to go about making it
like that I just I made a I called it a
vicious cycle I made a logo I wanted
people to know what I was doing
I made paracord bracelets to fun the
jury initially so by wanting him to Nora
is doing I basically made a post on
Facebook I'm selling make hand making
and selling these paracord bracelets if
you know anyone that would like to buy
one that would be awesome I don't want
free money you know I sold him for like
20 bucks each and made 300 something of
them and and so I think through my
facebook pages how like the New York
Times contact me and I asked him how
they heard about it and they just
replied with the Facebook page right I
still don't know exactly and so some of
the news out it's just kind of been a
whirlwind in a way I mean the the
message is important in I'm I've decided
early on to welcome anything like that
mm-hmm
because this journey did help me and I
know that talking about the issues along
the way and and publicly you know to the
news and everything is me
a difference I mean if if this is
inspired even one other veteran to to go
out and do something like this rather
than take their own life like that's
enough for me yeah so sick of us dying
honestly so and I didn't want to add to
it so I started this on that note I want
to wind this down with some words around
the veteran experience like what are we
not getting what do we misunderstand
about the veteran experience I think
part of it honestly I think maybe would
be sometimes putting us on a pedestal or
something or kind of viewing us as
different when really we just want to we
don't want the attention necessarily we
just want to be making a difference kind
of behind the scenes in a way so maybe
that is a aspect of it or on I think
just sometimes maybe key questions or
ones that shouldn't probably be asked it
just casually like did you see any body
parts or did kill anyone stuff like that
no just in casual Congress and avoiding
that but like the plague you know and
now I know as far as there's a lot of
resources and more and more coming into
play that's why part of my thing is
contributing to the solution here and
there's a lot of new organizations and
programs that are available now that
where can people go to learn about that
like what are some of those there's a
actually there's a really good resource
that I know of connecting vets org they
post a lot of different options places
to go and it's not just called a suicide
hotline
you know they call it the hotline like
it's the 900 number something but they
they always are they seem like they're
really up-to-date on a lot of different
options for veterans mm-hmm so that's
one I know of for sure and the the VFW
in American Legion are already in place
you know
and when I went around to them before I
started back out I visited as many VFW's
as I could because at that point I was
like I want to get my message out there
I tell him what I'm doing and I was
completely welcomed in right away it
wasn't just about joining her let's talk
about war stuff I mean it was just
casual fun like lots of swearing and and
having a lot of laughter and just us
being how kind of how we were when we
were in and things so those are very
helpful I believe if do you think not
enough veterans take advantage of those
opportunities especially veterans my age
I think they have a this perceived
notion that you know it's all that's
like a drama veteran all these super old
guys are gonna be yeah and there are
there is some of that I mean quite no to
that because of this so yeah getting I
think a younger generations into the VFW
and American legions and AM vets or I
mean if you have a motorcycle you know
there's the combat veterans Motorcycle
Association and there's tons of
motorcycle clubs super patriotic a lot
of veteran run ones mm-hmm so I think it
just takes some putting yourself out
there I think that's the key for
veterans to put themselves out there and
and for civilians just maybe I guess
just kind of being casual and treating
them kind of like they're there like you
or something like that right and for
those civilians who happen to have
veterans in their lives other family
members or friends what are some of the
warning signs that that that veteran
perhaps is suffering and what is the
best way to approach that with I think
some of the warning signs would be the
isolation or maybe actually quite a bit
of happiness out of nowhere for a while
something like that
making it a point to spend important
time with as many people as possible on
a whim could maybe be a sign that
something's coming up it's not too good
like they don't want to be alone like
almost in a manic way ou know that
possibly they're trying to make these
quick memories and best and great times
with people because their planning may
be on to something themselves like the
signs like that's interesting
um cuz that's that was kind of part of
my thought process it was visit as much
family and friends as possible send
photos of me with them so that they have
them get all these things in place you
know things like that so it would be the
least hurtful to them that sort of
mindset but um and I've and I've had
there's been veterans that have done
that that sort behavior and then
followed through to making kind of big
financial decisions or really that that
sort of thing big purchases even maybe
trying desperately to have that
excitement or fulfillment or something
and then it's and probably won't work
you know buying yeah crazy amount of
stuff for for helping it's a lot to ask
but I just don't give up on the person
but it's so much easier to say than do I
I know but um even if they're not
showing much or don't seem as
appreciative or thankful a lot of times
you're making the the difference you
know I'm not encouraging an unhealthy or
dangerous relationship to continue if it
shouldn't but if if they know that
you're that having you is that constant
or knowing that constants there could be
the one thing that that's keeping them
from from ending it or doing something
wild dangerous to themselves or someone
else having a constant of some sort and
if you're that constant for a veteran
just oh I hate to say hang in there but
a lot of times
yeah if possible you know or try to
approach it in that way where it's like
you know I'm I'm here for you and
knowing someone's there is important
right
but I know not a lot gets accomplished
this by saying I'm there for you but
just by by actually physically being
present and consistently showing you
know that they can come to you when
they're ready or confide in you and the
less pressure that you're available
right yeah that's really helpful I think
that's all like super important
information and we got to we got to wrap
this up but I just wanted to end it with
saying that there are a lot of people
out there who are suffering a lot of
them are suffering in silence so if you
are listening to this and you are one of
those people or there is somebody in
your life that you know is suffering
that there is help available please
reach out for help don't try to solve
this problem on your own raise your hand
make your voice heard seek out the
resources in your community and the
people that you trust confide in them
tell them what's going on be honest
find those resources that Sarah
mentioned I'm sure if you google you
know this stuff there's going to be
plenty of things available at your
fingertips and to not do it alone right
the fact that 22 veterans take their
lives every day is is devastating and
for all of those people out there that
are listening that suffer from PTSD who
are not veterans I'm speaking about you
as well and thank you for sharing your
story here today it's super
inspirational amazing that you were able
to climb out of that and now be of
service to other people I feel like you
should get on a bike ride that rides up
up to the US Capitol and that a group of
you can can have your voices be heard in
Washington DC so that at least at the
highest level from the top down were
addressing and redressing this problem
ya know thank you so much for saying
that and having me and I think once
people are
allowing that support to come in it's
it's gonna be overwhelming what what's
in place already in your life that you
might have become blind to having fallen
into a rut or a dark place you know when
you're at the bottom it's hard to see
what's really going on so that's really
important because you may have convinced
yourself that everyone will be okay but
they won't they never will be the same
so and sometimes it is those tiny
gestures that can make a huge difference
right what's next for you I am going to
continue to focus on building my
nonprofit Waypoint vets
waypoint vets dot org and I'm going to
be I'm playing for my 501 and that's the
first big step right aside from that
that's like the whole thing getting that
yes yeah yeah I want to do it right the
first time
you know I need to build an inventory
gear camping fishing hiking canoeing
kayaking cycling caving excited caving
yes like in caves not like when you
caving no I know what you're saying yeah
that's cool like all different kinds of
cool adventures yes yep this adventure
either preferably overnight adventures
where you bond over camp at the end of
the day after an emotionally and
physically taxing day there's nothing
beats just kicking back and being among
like-minded I mean other veterans so
much healing happens from detaching in
nature with other vets just I you know
realized a firsthand so that's
definitely what I want and need to do
it's gonna keep me here for sure yeah
that's awesome well thank you for
sharing your story people are listening
having me to this and they want to
they're falling in love with you and
they want to connect with you how do
they
is there a worship where should they go
to your Facebook page where's the best
place yes that I would say go ahead and
go to a vicious cycle
org or Waypoint vets dot org I have an
email and I have a Facebook page for
both also facebook.com slash a vicious
cycle and slash Waypoint vets and I
check my messages
all the time I message with veterans all
the time and it's actually it's very
comfortable too we just send back and
forth whenever and you could say or not
say whatever it it's nice you know it
works it works it's helped me it's
helped others so message any time I will
I will answer so awesome thank you thank
you for your service then and thank you
for your service now how you feel you
feel okay yeah we good yes all right
cool
awesome we'll come back and talk to me
again sometime if you'll have me I would
be honored thanks sir thank you so much
peace
[Music]